une solution trouver en urgence dans
l'impossibilité de s'installer sur leur
nouvelle terre à dainville agathe guérin
fabien le cow et dick et leurs animaux
se sont établies provisoirement depuis
le mois de mars dans l'ancien haras des
bréviaires du fait du harcèlement
judiciaire
la famille d'agriculteurs qui voulait
s'implanter se retrouve sans crédit
bancaire pour pouvoir acquérir ces
terres et pour pouvoir faire les
investissements nécessaires
donc je chante au bord de la faillite de
la ruine des paires prêté par le
département des yvelines qui permettent
aux éleveurs d'abriter leurs bêtes le
temps que la bataille juridique
initiée notamment par l'éditrice odile
jacob ne cesse il ya des vaches il ya
des ja des chevaux on a essayé de faire
survivre notre notre élevage une autre
activité à l'école c'est précaire est
temporaire bas pour l'instant c'est pas
la suite des événements certainement qui
va se passer quelque chose après tout ça
l'exemple de cette famille n'est pas un
cas isolé dans les yvelines
c'est pourquoi le département réfléchit
à une solution plus globale à mettre en
place chaque fois nous réfléchissons
c'est la création d'un fonds cogéré avec
la chambre d'agriculture qui permettrait
de régler justement ces problèmes parce
que là vous avez une famille qui est
concerné et ça a été très médiatisée
parce que les plaignants contre eux sont
des gens très médiatique mais il ya eu
d'autres exemples identique
quant au haras des bréviaires qui
n'était plus destiné à accueillir de
l'élevage les élus locaux
l'intercommunalité de rambouillet
territoire et le département étudie des
projets de reconversion du domaine pour
le futur